مع الاخذ في الاعتبار ان لدينا 190 قوميه
تعيش في البلاد وعليه سنتناول اليوم هذه
القضايا في اطار مساله ضمان امن روسيا
[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم على وقع هجمات على منشات
حيويه روسيه بوتين يقول انه لن يسمح لمن
وصفهم بالاعداء بزعزعه اوضاع بلاده
ومستشار الامن القومي الامريكي يحذر من
احتمالات نشوب حرب نوويه ويقول ان بوتين
شرع في اتخاذ خطوات لنشر اسلحه النوويه في
بيلاروسيا ويبدي استعدادا لمفاوضات مع
روسيا والصين للحد من التسلح النوويه بعد
فرض واشنطن عقوبات على اطراف الصراع في
السودان الجيش يقول انما تقوم به امريكا
لن يؤثر كثيرا وقوات الدعم السريع ترى ان
العقوبات اثبتت في السابق عدم جدواها ورغم
تعليق محادثات جده كيربي يقول للجزيره انه
لا تراجع عن السعي لايجاد حل سياسي للازمه
رغم تصاعد الضغوط الدبلوماسيه الاوروبيه
على بريشتينا وبيجراد لوقف التصعيد الصربي
يواصلون احتجاجاتهم في شمال كوسوفو وفي
تصريحات الجزيره قائد قوات حفظ السلام
التابعه لنيتو يحذر من خطوره التصعيد اذا
لم يتم التوصل الى حل بعد تقارير اشارت
الى تلقيه عرضا للعب في السعوديه النجم
الفرنسي كريم بنزيما يقول انه فخور
ومستمتع باللعب مع ريال مدريد في الوقت
الحالي تاركا الباب مفتوحا امام جميع
الاحتمالات حول مستقبله مع النادي الملكي
الى اللقاء